Everyone thinks you're, like,
Johnny Superstar over here.
- Yeah.
- Like, you must've been
sex, drugs and rock 'n' roll
in college.
- Right?
- Right, yeah.
- But, like, we know that
you're this—
When was the first time
you had a drink?
- 22 years old was the first time
I had a drink.
- Damn.
- But you did have a drink at 22?
- Yeah, I did.
- Why all of a sudden?
- Well...
it was, uh, to impress a chick.
- Ohh.
- We were in Vegas.
We went to Tao.
And this was back when Tao was
like, you know,
it was at its highest.
- Big time.
- It was at its peak.
- Huge Buddha—
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, huge Buddha.
Right.
- Champagne bottles, you know
coming nonstop,
and the first drink
I decide is gonna be
my first drink ever is Patron.
- Ooh.
- Straight from the bottle.
No chasers.
Just straight tequila.
- What I can't get over is,
you're Reggie Bush
and you're the man,
and you needed
the liquid courage?
- For whatever reason...
I needed the liquid courage
to get me there.
- You did.
- To get me to that point.
And I blacked out.
- Right.
- I wake up the next morning.
There's—my throat is burning.
I don't know why my
throat's burning.
Then I look on the side
of the bed.
There's throw-up all
on the side of the bed.
- Ohh.
- And I'm like, "Damn."
Like, "What happened?"
- [Laughing]
- I got the hangover from hell.
- The hangover.
- The hangover from hell.
So I'm, like, drinking water
and all kinds of stuff.
The next day,
all my boys was like
"Man, you were
on fire last night."
I was like, "Really?
What'd I do?"
One of my other boys was like
"You turned into
the Incredible Hulk.
Like, you just get really strong
for no reason."
They were like,
"You were pickin' people up
you were movin' people
out the way."
- Oh my God. I've seen
those guys before.
You were Frank the Tank
that night.
- Yeah, I was Frank the Tank.
- So big star, Heisman Trophy,
rich Reggie Bush—
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Did it work at least?
- It did.
- OK.
- Um, it worked.
Um, but...yeah, it was just
one of those—
- There was a big price to pay.
- It was a big price to pay.